AMC's The Walking Dead has become a staple
of Sunday television, endlessly shocking and
delighting fans with its gory action and non-stop
drama.
The grim apocalyptic series has gotten increasingly
violent over the years, to the point that
some fans have even called it quits because
of the alarming brutality, while others have
become irked by some key changes from the
original comic's scenes.
But even those who've stuck around from the
start still might be surprised to find out
these facts about the series.
From on-set hijinks to spoiler maintenance
problems, here's what you may not know about
The Walking Dead...
Taking the lead
In a major case of Hollywood sliding doors,
Andrew Lincoln almost wasn't cast as Sheriff
Rick Grimes because he'd accepted a role in
another film at the time.
But life got in the way: his second child
was born shortly before the film was expected
to commence production, so Lincoln decided
against shooting it after all.
He told The Hollywood Reporter, "I got a friend
to replace me in this movie and the next day,
this script came through from AMC.
I must have been on their radar with Frank
[Darabont], and he wanted me to test.
It was incredible."
What got him to agree to take the audition
to begin with, he later revealed, was the
fact that executive producer and show co-creator
Frank Darabont was involved.
He believed that meant the show could have
a real future that made moving his growing
family worth it.
As he told Rolling Stone, "Frank talked us
into getting on that plane."
SWAT team swarm
During production on the second episode of
the inaugural season, The Walking Dead's cast
and crew got an unexpected set of visitors:
a SWAT team.
Mearle actor Michael Rooker was on a rooftop
shooting his rifle to simulate a zombie sniper
session, but onlookers mistook his behavior
for the real deal — and called in the cops.
"I saw people jump and run.
They had already dispatched the SWAT team.
The officer said, 'Please, stand down.'"
It wasn't the last time a false alarm would
ring regarding the show.
In 2016, a Great Falls, Montana, family found
themselves swarmed by police after neighbors
called in a possible domestic violence incident
involving guns inside their home … because
they were watching the show loud enough for
neighbors to think a big shootout was going
down.
Pulling pranks
For a show with such grisly material as The
Walking Dead, its stars sure know how to have
fun when the cameras aren't rolling.
Actor Norman Reedus in particular has a long-running
history of pranking Andrew Lincoln and others
during production.
Some of his greatest hits from the thick history
book of their prank wars include Reedus filling
Lincoln's car vents with glitter so that it
exploded all over him as soon as he cranked
the A/C. Then there was the time he taught
Lincoln to greet Japanese fans with the phrase
"where's the toilet" when he wanted to say
"thank you for allowing me to be here."
Lincoln's been known to get him back on occasion,
too, like when he put Reedus' treasured motorcycle
on a boat with a sex doll and sent it sailing
to the middle of a lake.
But the best is when he gets more precise
forms of payback.
"Believe me, this is the end.”
AMC Easter eggs
The Walking Dead is an Easter egg lover's
dream, because the show is filled with hidden
tributes to the original comics, other zombie
epics, and plenty more.
AMC's sister hit Breaking Bad received some
of the most clever winks and references.
For instance, there was the Heisenberg-blue
meth that appeared in a bag of drugs shown
in the second season.
And let's not forget when Daryl Dixon basically
described his brother's dealer — and Jesse
Pinkman fit the description to a tee.
"Merle had this dealer.
This janky little white guy.
He says ‘I'm gonna kill you bitch.’”
The connections have been significant enough
to even inspire some theorists to connect
the timelines of the two shows and posit a
cause-and-effect relationship between Walter
White's chemical concoction and the onset
of the zombie plague.
"Yeah Mr. White.
Yeah science!"
Hey, anything's possible!
The Walking Dead has still yet to explain
where and why the walker infection happened.
Irking the neighbors
You might think living in a small town where
one of TV's biggest hits is made would be
a treat.
But for some residents of Senoia, Georgia,
the experience of becoming a mini-Hollywood
has been unpleasant at times.
As reported by ABC News, some of Senoia's
natives have been annoyed by being asked to
change their activities in their hometown
as a result of its proximity to the set — from
taking pictures to trimming trees, show officials
have stepped in to moderate what would otherwise
be considered pretty ordinary behaviors.
"And they come out of there sayin’ I need
to stop, they’re filming.
Uh, I said ‘Well no, you just carry your
happy butt right behind the wall.’”
Set attention has also spawned an army of
"Walker Stalkers" — that is, fans who case
the town in hopes of catching a glimpse — which
is both a business boon and a headache for
locals, especially when explosive scenes are
being shot nearby one of the neighborhoods.
To compensate for the troubles, though, some
families are paid a monthly stipend of $400,
and others have received in-person thanks
from some of the cast.
Earning outrage
While plenty of devastating character deaths
have happened on The Walking Dead over the
years, one killing in particular had commentators
in a tizzy.
In the sixth season, Merritt Wever's Dr. Denise
Cloyd was killed off.
And it wasn't just the fact that she died
in a way that, in the comics, happened to
Abraham.
Instead, it was the fact that her death added
to a growing trend of that season in which
lesbian characters were routinely and unceremoniously
executed on various shows.
The show was immediately panned after the
episode aired for playing into the "bury your
gays" trope that seemed to be so common in
mainstream television in 2016.
Of the controversy, Wever herself told The
Daily Beast, "I hadn't thought about it that
way.
… I'm not sure that that's what was going
on here but I understand the sentiment very
well."
Avoiding the amputation
One of the most glaring omissions from The
Walking Dead's transformation from book to
screen has been the fact that Rick's still
got both of his hands.
In the comics, The Governor cuts off Rick's
right hand — his shooter side, no less.
So when the Governor arrived on-screen in
the third season, many readers were braced
for the inevitable.
But it never happened.
There have been a couple minor winks to the
event, like Merle — a character unique to
the show — having to cut off his own hand
to escape being handcuffed to a rooftop.
And then there was the time the villainous
Negan threatened to cut off Carl's hand in
the seventh season.
But Rick's still working with two fully functional
fists.
So what gives?
In his Reddit AMA series, the comic book's
co-creator Robert Kirkman explained the decision
as a matter of practicality, and the simple
of filming a TV show: saying:
"To clarify, I think cutting Rick's hand [off]
when we did was GREAT for the comic.
It's just that in another medium it would
be harder to pull off, we cheat in the comic
because things aren't moving.
You can't do that on the show.
You'd see Rick not being able to reload his
gun, and things like that.
The CGI of cutting off Rick's hand would be
expensive, but we did it with Hershel's leg
so if we felt strongly about Rick losing a
hand, we'd do it."
Optimistic end game
The show may have diverged from writer Robert
Kirkman's ongoing comic series in some significant
ways, but he still has a lot of creative influence
on The Walking Dead production.
According to him, fans can expect the ending
to both versions to be hopeful.
He said, "It's a very popular show, and [the
executives at AMC] seem to want it to go for
50 seasons.
And it may go for 50 seasons, but there is
definitely an end point at some point…
I see the story from beginning to end, over
many, many years, so I think it's a very hopeful
story about humanity overcoming this insurmountable,
apocalyptic situation.
… It's just gonna take them a long time
to do it."
But until then,we'll all just enjoy the grim
ride.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!